there's a species of cicada that only
emerges every 17 years
and guess what they'll be emerging this
week
yeah it's crazy they've spent the last
17 years underground
and this is amazing we have one of the
cicadas and he's here with us
tonight hello there cicada hey going
hey uh thanks for being here this is
incredible
your species can stay dormant
underground for 17 years
yeah yeah whatever it's not a big deal
what is a big deal is how much pop
culture i've missed out on
i need you to catch me up tell me
everything sure what do you want to know
okay so one thing i've been thinking
about for the last 17 years is
whether my favorite singer r kelly
released a new album
oh um yeah sorry to be the one to tell
you but r kelly
did some he did some bad stuff and he's
in jail now
no what oh man
well okay well tell me this has my
favorite author jk rowling released a
new book
oh yeah jk rowling she said some stuff
um
people didn't love and i i don't think
there's a new book series
oh okay well what about my favorite
comedian
bill cosby it's not good
my favorite news anchor matt lauer no
okay what about my favorite film and
television producer harvey weinstein
that's a big no my favorite politician
andrew cuomo my favorite socialite and
financier jeffrey epstein
my favorite circuit court judge brett
kavanaugh my favorite black activist
rachel dolezal
no look i'm sorry it's maybe it's better
if you just let them all go
and start over fresh you know wow
i really know how to pick losers huh at
least it's nice being here back with you
here on nbc
oh come on you really didn't hear any
news over the last
17 years i'm a cicada conan anyway
i'm not going to ask you about my
favorite celebrity couple because i
already know the answer i'm sure they
broke up
probably who was it ben affleck and
jennifer lopez
well actually that's interesting they
just got back together
really benefit is back benifer is back
thank you coden you've made the cicada
very happy
do you know what we do when we're happy
no what
oh my god oh that's terrible
i'm so happy i can't stop ah
all right we have a great show uh dion
cole
is on the progress knock it off dion
cole's here we'll
see in a second oh no
stop it